this is a production of cornell
university
uh thanks for coming so a lot of you
guys know me i'm dan buckley so i am new
to this program
just since
january uh as the dgs and and very much
marvin and tara are the sort of heart
and soul of the program and certainly we
couldn't be here without everything
they've been doing so uh i've been
learning a lot about this program from
them and from you over the last few
months
and
you know this symposium one of the
reasons we're here is to sort of learn
more about what you're doing um and it's
also a recognition of what you've
accomplished so we're gonna have a
graduation ceremony uh in a couple of
days uh and that's a chance for you to
sort of be honored but this is a chance
for you to sort of tell us a little bit
about what you have been doing
and just to share that and to recognize
that
um
what i would say that i've learned so
far about this program
uh it's remarkable in a few ways in that
it's super diverse um i mean the school
of integrative plant sciences is
amazingly diverse we have 80 faculty who
just i mean yeah we study plants but we
study microbes interacting with plants
we study soils we're out in the field
we're in the lab we're doing molecular
biology like
we are incredibly diverse and so the
students in this program represent that
diversity we have more than 50 advisors
that are in our program now and people
are joining all the time and you all
have worked with a wide cross-section of
the faculty within sips you know your
own primary advisors as well as
other faculty you've interacted with so
the program is super diverse and so
that's one reason i'm looking forward to
seeing what you guys have to say because
i think i'm going to learn a lot about
the kind of stuff we do here
the other thing i'd say is that i've
learned the students are like
super ambitious and highly motivated
like i talk to faculty in different
units
uh you know how are you doing with mps
students how do you find them in the
classes and i only ever hear great
things you know they're super motivated
they're organized they know what they
want to do
like they just have great things to say
about you
so that's another reason why i'm looking
forward to seeing what you have to
present because i think you know this is
just fantastic stuff and i want to hear
what you guys have been working on
the other thing that i think is
remarkable about this program other than
our students and our university is um
it's hard right i mean you guys have a
lot of graduate level coursework to cram
in the two semesters and it's a struggle
to get all that stuff done and then you
have the capstone project
and our undergrads just had a symposium
last week i mean they get years to
figure out what they're doing right our
ms and phd students
i mean they're here for years to figure
this stuff out you guys have
a year and many of you have finished in
two semesters right that's remarkable
and i think the most remarkable thing
about it isn't
necessarily the work that you've done on
the capstone project
it's just getting started it's
identifying the problem so one of the
things when you're an undergrad your
faculty give you
uh the questions and you give them
answers right you take a test hear the
questions hear the answers boom it's
hard to provide an answer to a question
way harder to come up with the question
itself and that's what the capstone
project makes you do it makes you throws
you in
in the fall like come up with a capstone
project go
and you guys freaked out right you're
like what am i gonna do with my capstone
project and you start talking to faculty
and talk to each other
and it's a bit of a crisis
and part of it is that that's what the
real world is like you know the real
world isn't just here's a question give
me the answer i mean sometimes it is but
when you get to the level that you guys
are at now we expect you to be able to
lead and that means defining the
questions and what are the questions
worth asking what are the questions we
need to invest in
that's hard stuff and i think you guys
have figured that out and so what we're
doing today with these lightning talks
isn't like here's this big manifesto
here's this big dissertation it's really
here's my question this is a question
that i found worthwhile that i'm
investing in maybe i've already started
to answer it maybe i'm going to answer
it this summer
we're not as much interested in the
answer we want to know what's your
question and why do you think it's
important and that's why i think these
lightning talks are really exciting and
fun
and i'm looking forward to what you guys
have to say
but so catherine i'm gonna go ahead and
yield the floor to you if you want to
get started and i'm just gonna leave
this here in case
okay great thank you dan and thank you
tara for organizing all of this i miss
you all a lot i wish i was in the room
so thanks for accommodating me here on
zoom
and i'd like to first and foremost thank
my advisor for all of his support
throughout my capstone development and
i'm excited to present a really short
summary
today so
uh my project is titled how can
voluntary carbon markets work for small
farmers
and i'll just quickly explain voluntary
carbon markets i'll refer to them as vcm
essentially are the voluntary buying and
selling of carbon offsets
and carbon offsets essentially represent
an amount of avoided or reduced
emissions
so in this first slide i'll just talk
about what i did and the second slide
i'll describe some potential solutions
to this question
so my goal was really to explore how can
these programs better serve small
farmers
and small farmers essentially face high
barriers to entry to participate in bcm
yet represent approximately 52
of the us in farmland in acres so their
sequestration potential should not be
ignored
and the first three objectives i set out
to answer this questions were first just
to explain the context in which these
markets are growing
secondly i was
curious and
if i could quantify the rise of
agriculture's participation in vcm
and an appoint important point here
excuse me is really answering the
question why is offsetting contentious
so happy to talk more offline about that
but
the crux of the capstone was really this
third objective here
where i was investigating these barriers
to entries entry
and credibility concerns
due to issues of effectively measuring
credits
and
equity of the market participants
so
that's just to lay out the context and
we can move to the next slide
thank you
so you know the heart of the capstone is
you know answering a question answering
a question with some solutions so here's
my effort in trying to pose
a solution to how can these programs
better serve small farmers and i've
ultimately concluded these
uh a solution would stem from three
pillars of change so firstly
is behavioral and i
would urge vcm to implement a bottom-up
approach for farmers instead of a
top-down
approach conventional in the market
and i secondly decided regionalizing
programs would also better serve small
producers and
for that i conducted a spatial analysis
in gis would be happy to share that at a
later time but
essentially wanted to identify u.s
counties with high sequestration
potential
and thirdly is a technological
investment to help
lower those fixed
costs that are very hard to overcome to
participate in the market and have a
local implementation solution paired to
help people actually implement uh
technology versus
sort of dropping it and walking it away
um
so that's very very brief summary and i
try to keep it at three minutes i think
i'm a little over but thank you so much
i'm glad i'm able to just share
highlight of the presentation today
hi uh good morning everyone my name is
paul and uh my advisors were don macau
and sonia and uh sonia scalia and dr
monk vision and uh sorry doctor carl dr
yeah so uh my
capstone project is on kelly alliance
reading
uh italia alliance orchids for singapore
and the tropical lowlands and my
capstone was creating a review and
breeding resource for this group of
orchids so carrier were once synonymous
with orchids and grown uh widely as cut
flowers and as corsage flowers in the
united states although the majority of
reading is now mainly in taiwan and
japan and um
yeah sort of one synonymous with
orchids but they've lost a lot of their
market share to other forms of orchids
and you can only really see them at
special shows and hobbyist conventions
and they're just like studying and
beautiful there you know they can get up
to like eight some of them may even 10
or 11 inches across and but the only
problem is that most of them only last
for about two weeks and the rest of the
time the commercial hobbyist that
commercial growers growing them for like
the rest of the year so it kind of has a
very low flying yield and long
generation time so these are some of the
issues as well in um
in
the tropics in particular and in
singapore there are only 101 registered
kellya hybridge as opposed to 3217
habits of all other orchid genera and
worldwide worldwide
they comprise only 10 of new
registrations and it's been stagnant
over the past few decades in addition
there's a lot of inappropriate selection
of plants for the tropics as uh quite a
lot of the relatives which were great
for the cut flower trade in the u.s
actually come from more tempered regions
and higher elevations whereas there
actually quite a lot of species which
are adapted to the tropical lowlands but
because the initial uh very complex
breeding was done with these relatives
which are
uh not too adapted to the low lens
there's this bias that the plants like
don't
really work in tropical areas and the
information about this genesis spread
over a variety of natural or varying
vigor so my aim was of course to compile
all of this and have a resource for
people and gardens in the tropics so in
terms of my methodology
i compiled records um
in various like media and literature
about kelly alliance that demonstrated
sustained growth and flowering in
singapore and i came up with a heuristic
to help identify like which what are
some
uh relatives and progeny progenitors in
hybrid backgrounds which enable them to
do this uh of all the members i've
identified
i search the literature for what
characteristics they impart to their
progeny because there's not been a lot
of a like uh compared to what we do with
say like wheat or other ornamental crops
they don't really have vegetarian like
genetic paper like mark uh papers we do
with the markers and other areas of the
genome so it's it's a lot of very like
observational
uh things based on phenotype and um i
compared the strategies in the cation
lines leading to what has been done with
other uh groups of awkward in singapore
and turns out they're actually like a
lot of parallels with these strategies
and
i outlined several goals um
species and hybrids which a person might
want to use if they want to achieve
certain goals in breeding these plants
and lastly i'm
including a chapter about supplemental
horticultural techniques such as virus
control and
growing under led lights in order to
provide a centralized resource for this
as well so in terms of results
like part of the limitation for
flowering or catelyn the tropics appears
to be some relationship with uh
with day length sensitivity and
requiring a temperature drop although
there's not really like very clear
studies on it like there's some papers
which suggest that a certain species can
be long day and others which suggest
it's short day and overall like it is
probably some sort of like source sink
balance like it is for a majority of
plants and um
as well as
some selection pressure in cultivation
and um i identified the different
species and hybrids for targeted color
combinations and patterns and the
interesting thing is that you can use
like different comp like species which
can look completely different to
accomplish what looks like almost an
exactly the same hybrids but this would
also imply that even though you are
getting the same goal there are actually
different
parameters for how you can best
cultivate and grow them so i suggested
some combinations if you would like to
grow in a more equatorial equatorial and
tropical climate and a lot another issue
is that a lot of the trendy breeding
plants for the hobbyist market which are
more compact and smaller are actually
not very well adapted to the tropics so
this is again a reoccurring issue and i
uh propose some suggestions to doing so
and of course there's some difficulties
as well because some there are some
species for desired colored like colors
like miniature red or pure white or
white with a colored lip which just
don't really do well on the topic so
there's some other suggestions for that
and um i
and i'm also reviewing like the other
supplemental horticultural techniques as
i mentioned and finally with regards to
advice from my project i'm really
looking for people who can give me
advice on web scraping because it will
help me like deal a lot with the larger
data sets so thank you that's all
hi i'm robin my advisor was david rosner
and this is my capstone
so i was hoping to develop an
interactive map of u.s natural disasters
using open source tools
so the goal of this was for just for me
to kind of learn the tools and software
and how to and just be able to show that
i can use these to develop a sort of
interactive user interface in order to
display and interact with data and
information
so i used r through rstudio and i also
used our packages including a shiny
leaflet
diaper
and tidy verse in order to do this i got
my data from the federal emergency
management agency and the u.s census
peru
so what i ended up creating was
this
interactive
map interface where you can select the
date range and the type of disaster and
it will just um adjust the
output of the map based on the
parameters um and create like sort of uh
bi-county um
points uh based on the uh sizing based
on the number of total like disasters
within the uh gate range selected
uh so
yeah that was basically it i managed to
uh show
that i could use these tools and
i hope to further develop this sometimes
thank you
[Applause]
hello everyone my name is luka
malayashuic i'm from serbia
and today i'll be talking about my
capstone project which is on the topic
of
actual manual for canola growers for
efficient crop protection and management
and the future potentials for canola
growth and the market growth of canola
as a crop in serbia
my academic advisor is dr antonio
ditomaso
so basically why i've chosen this
project is because
my uh background academic background was
also in plant protection but i've never
had quite the opportunity to explore
canola as a crop or rather any prop in
that sense through the whole growth
stage and its management and crop
protection background so
this project will actually focus on the
integration
of the cultivation of canola of like
soil preparation weeds pathogens how to
manage them how to manage pests
and to maximize yield and productivity
and then the second part is actually the
question that i want to answer
that's what's the future potential of
the economic growth of um canola within
the market of serbia because where i
come from this crop has just started
becoming more popular in like uh
2009-2000
after the 2008 market crash the prices
have stabilized
the crop has become more stable and
the potentials for its growth has
risen dramatically
and then
going through the segments uh
i will be covering like canola as an oil
crop its importance as uh it's the third
most important oil crop in the world
after
palm oil and soybean oil and then canola
production cultivation on a global level
uh the main pathogens in their
management insects and the management uh
the weeds aspect and the management of
wheats on the side i've also done a
little small project uh in the weeds
management in the critical period of
weed management in canola as a crop
and have found that the main
time when to tackle the weeds is between
the fourth and sixth leaf of canola
also tackling the optimal fertilization
practices
and then introducing a little bit of the
history of canola growth in serbia and
why it's important as a crop
and then answering the question of the
future economic canola market potential
and if it's going to rise in the acreage
uh in the future and whether uh it's
better to explore the markets of oil or
biofuels
that would be all thank you
hey everybody i'm jonah goldstein uh
very thankful to my advisors dr don
raykow and dr sanjeli um as well as the
rest of my cohort in public garden
leadership
and sips
so my project
is on potential collaboration between
community schools and public gardens uh
if community schools are an unfamiliar
term to you you're not alone that's a
big reason why i'm doing this project
so what's the issue that i'm tackling
schools have varying degrees of
opportunity for students to engage in
experiential learning particularly
nature based learning
you know largely the opportunities you
have at a school are determined by the
zip code right by the tax base how much
funding that school gets the u.s is an
absolute nightmare of economic disparity
uh and it's getting worse by the day
and many schools in america
unfortunately look like this
uh some also look like this i thought
this was a prison
it's a school uh and that unfortunately
leads to some of this
so
how can we tackle this public gardens
are perfectly positioned to help expand
korean programming at schools
um public gardens are institutions that
are rooted in place that are you know
they're geographically based they have a
large
staff large educational programming
potential
and amazing resources when it comes to
plants
so i've been talking to public gardens
that have
education programs
that other gardens could potentially
model
this is work that don has done a lot of
in terms of looking at these kinds of
programs
i'm looking specifically at school
collaboration so naples botanic garden
in florida they have a program called
dirtmade my lunch it's where kids work
with edible plants
they learn about where their food's
coming from they get to take home a
tomato seedling they also have a program
called collier greens that's a teach the
teachers program
so they're training teachers to do
garden-based programming after school
training teachers also to establish
community gardens
um just to expand their impact
essentially denver botanic gardens also
has some very innovative programming in
this respect
uh they have this really ambitious
program called growing scientists it's a
collaboration um with a number of
cultural institutions in the area uh all
working together to apply jointly for
grant funding um in order to carry out
some pretty ambitious educational
program that takes place at each
institution
uh cornell botanic gardens also has some
school programs um
honest only food crops right a rare
acknowledgement of our stolen land
as well as plants have families
which is about
the
genetic lineage of plants and how all
that works
so what are community schools community
schools are schools that have adopted a
community school model essentially
strengthening their resources their
available programming and opportunities
for students by an extensive network of
partnerships organizational partnerships
often with non-profits
so community schools have infrastructure
to support collaborative programming and
that's what makes them so important to
public gardens because public gardens
it takes a lot of resources from them
to run a program with the school some
really large institutions this isn't too
much of a problem like brooklyn botanic
garden you know they they're very very
well established um they can dedicate a
lot of resources to transportation to
outreach to forming those relationships
but smaller or newer gardens don't have
that and so when they need to be more
strategic about how to form their
programming they can look to community
schools community schools have dedicated
site coordinators that's a point person
who will interface with different
organizations they're often sort of
leading the charge when it comes to
outreach for partnerships
they have goal-oriented community
engagement teams so i worked at a
community school in rochester that had
what was called cets community
engagement teams that were each
dedicated to a different focus so as
the person focusing on green initiatives
as part of the health and wellness
community engagement team they have
robust community outreach um and family
relationships that are built on trust
often
um the partners that community schools
will make will also provide important
services you know for things like
housing and food security and so
community schools are able to do what's
called a warm hand-off where that
organization will inherit the trust with
the families and students that this
school has established
uh they'll have extended learning time
that i was present at the school that i
um was based at in rochester um so time
after classes wrap up specifically
dedicated to things like project-based
or experiential learning um
and there it is that emphasis
and they also have me um or at least
some of them do
which is definitely an asset
thank you guys
[Applause]
hello my name is kylie bronius okay so i
did my project on the optimization of
habitat infrastructure sites for
connectivity of puma concolar habitat in
california
my advisor was diana sinton she was very
helpful throughout this
and so was david rossiter
so the motivations behind this project
there has been very low genetic
diversity observed in specifically the
santa monica mountain range in southern
california
a lot of mountain lion populations have
been isolated by major freeways
and
that's limiting the mating opportunities
for these populations so while there are
some land areas that are big enough
um
they're not really sustainable for a
population to thrive and reproduce
because it's causing a lot of inbreeding
and then population decline
there was a study done in which a lot of
pumas were tagged as gps callers and one
male from that study was able to cross
freeway 101 in 2009 and initiate what
was referred to as a genetic rescue
event
by meeting with several females on the
other side
so that was just served as evidence that
[Music]
these freeways are majorly inhibiting
those populations and if mountain lions
are able to cross that can be
really beneficial to helping them not
become endangered in those areas
mountain lions are very evasive of
humans and they need highly rocky slopes
and a lot of vegetative cover there was
one researcher involved in this study
who um
he was quoted in saying
that
i have a gps the mountain lion has a
collar i know he's 15 meters in front of
me but i never ever see them which i
thought was kind of cool
um and then recent bills provide funding
for habitat infrastructure such as land
bridges um to cross these major freeways
so this project was intended to kind of
decide how to allocate some of that
funding
so i was able to create
eight variations of a habitat
suitability model in california using
arcgis pro and data sourced from esri
the national hydrography dataset usgs
and a few other sources
i chose two region of interest one was
northern central california you can see
kind of
based on these studies um
that red region in the middle is like
the central valley where there's a lot
of crop land not a lot of sustainable
habitat and then
uh that eastern region is more forested
and then in southern california that's
more the santa monica region and like la
with a lot of those major freeways
interrupting
um and i was able to once i created
these models uh take them into
r and do some programming to get some
some metrics on the connectivity of
patches and the adjacency of certain
rated pixels these are rated on a scale
of one to five
um
once they were put into r um
so yeah i was able to identify patches
and um get some statistics on their
connectivity
and then from that i was able to create
these two
site optimization maps
these were pretty robust but based on
those suitability models
the highest suitability patches that
were ranked
number five
i was able to just define the major
points of intersection between these
major freeways and those high
suitability habitats so that
this is kind of a preliminary map you
can see some of the clustering
of where would be the best locations to
build those habitat infrastructure
across freeways
so yeah
thank you
hi everyone i'm deborah i'm soil and
crop sciences concentration and my
advisors dominic wolfe um
i really love hearing what you're all
working on by the way
um the title of my capstone is an
assessment of soil health research in
global cotton cropping systems under a
changing climate
so why cotton you might be thinking
it's a really really important cash crop
and source of income for millions of
farmers worldwide it's the most
important fiber crop and most used
natural fiber in the fashion and textile
industry where i worked for five years
before coming here
a few few key facts it's a 40 billion
dollar industry 25 million tons of lint
um which is after the seeds have been
removed from the fiber is produced per
annum it's grown in 80 countries
on a huge variety of different soil
types and climatic conditions and it
touches the lives of 100 million
different farmers
and in terms of the cotton production
today less than one percent is grown
organically it's actually 0.94
and that's been growing since the 1990s
steadily but obviously very slowly
and 25 is grown according to sustainable
standards and all of these logos
represent a different sustainable
standard a third of these are organic
and the others
really look to reduce the environmental
impacts of cotton through more efficient
use of resources but they're nowhere
near as prohibitive as organic
and a lot of them are starting to put
soil health more at the center so
they're kind of being revised as we
speak
but that means that that 74 of cotton is
being grown conventionally and there are
a lot of concerns around how poor
management practices have been really
maximizing yields but at the expense of
soil health and human health ecological
health
um
so the challenge is that cotton
production is projected to grow by 1.5
per annum until 2030
but in a lot of these systems there's
degraded and depleted soils
and there have been stagnant global
yields um since 2007 and so
opportunity on the other hand is that
the fashion industry is really excited
about soil health and the role that soil
carbon stocks can play in climate change
mitigation
um which is kind of why i came here to
look at really how to tap into the 74
um and increase adoption soil
conservation practices
and so the goal of my capstone is to
drive evidence-based approaches to land
management and policy to improve soil
quality and productivity in cotton-based
systems
and i intend to do this by reviewing and
synthesizing all the conservation
agriculture research that's looking at
cotton-based systems and identifying
gaps in those research so
in terms of outputs i'll be producing a
soil health cotton database
and then mapping that
to assess the spatial distribution and
concentration of that research against
cotton production distribution
to identify those gaps and then my
report will be
discussing the implications for the
fashion industry specifically looking at
how to best tailor conservation
practices according to cropping system
soil type and agroclimatic zone
but if you have any suggestions or have
done any research with cotton or know of
anyone i'd love to talk to you because i
know it's not really a crop that's
looked that much at cornell um but yeah
love to chat thank you for listening
[Applause]
hi everyone my name is
and my capsule
papers topic is comparison of two
agriculture systems in hubei province in
china and new york city
in united states and my advisor is peter
hobbs and my specialty is in soil and
crop science and giving a little bit
background on why i'm doing this because
after i finish this program i will be
going back to china and start a farm so
hopefully after like
diving more into the capstone paper i
will having a more general idea of how
like actually starting from
and
there are more some interesting and
focusing some is like
china and the u.s is kind of the two
biggest important exporter countries and
where what i have learned so far like uh
united states
definitely has more like efficient
maximum yield on each carbon land like
using less labor force and using more
mechanical machines but in other terms
that all contribute to many like nation
policies and the government or towards
that so my main objective is to
compare the similarity and differences
in the agriculture in china city which
the
city i was working on when i'm going
back and the top kings county which we
all live in here right now it's like
like where i'm more familiar with and
easy to get data to compare
and
and the second is to understand how you
unique the agriculture system have
arising in these two statical locations
which like um
sorry yeah and any management
suggestions can be made that's what i
trying to mean focus about because like
we're also facing the like popular
population increasing issues like in
2015 and
we like these two countries meaning like
feeding contributing feeding a lot of uh
people in other countries so which i am
more concerned about how to like
what we can learn from each other and
maximum the yield and contribute to like
feeding the the human
yeah
so
uh what i have mean like the mathematy
of my program is like meaning focus on
like
literature review and the library
research and
getting data from the government website
and compare them
and those are the main topics i have
developed that will be focusing on
talking one is farmland this is more
towards to nature hepatitis like
topography climate and soil
charistic and this is going to be
more towards to the crop like why this
nation gonna what type of crop and what
type of farm they're gonna have
and the next is the management sidewise
it's more towards to human management
it's like firm size and type and
mechanical use
and the controlling method of pests and
weed and it's gonna orb or tools to the
like what we have in the
in the nature size because what i have
and then the next is focus on marketing
and how where to sell and the storage
and what kind of effects of the price
and what's the component of profit in
both two countries
and the next is really important i think
it's one of the thing we have to
consider about is a government policy
because like uh what's what's the
biggest impact on the true agriculture
system i feel like other than the
nature-wise the government things like
chinese like
the land are owned by the government
like once because what i have learned
for now i have known that soil
sustainability and soil health is a
great really important component but
once i have talked to my dad about
what are we going to going to have a
farm like we're going to mainly focus on
the soil house but like what's really
sad like i heard from my daddy's like we
don't have to focus about that because
we don't only land like we don't know
like after 10 years where this peace
land gonna going to be and so that makes
me feel really sad and really want to
work on in the future
yeah
so
yeah thanks for listening and thanks
[Applause]
all right hello uh my name is wyatt
boone that's the wordy but basically i'm
looking at a dual process anaerobic and
aerobic digestion
of fish manure for hydroponic fertilizer
so
this basically all is aquaponics
so
i wasn't always into farming i used to
work in government that's where i
graduated my under degree or undergrad
degree but um i hated it and i wanted it
but i was interested in sustainability
so i and i lived in cities like most my
life are very close to cities so i
looked at aquaponics because this is and
hydroponics because aquaponics is
probably one of the most sustainable
systems you can have in a city and
having probably about the only kind of
livestock you can have in a city um so i
wasn't really sure who would be here
today so hopefully this isn't too basic
but basically aquaponics um you're most
of the time you are using the water that
the fish live in
to grow plants but first we have to put
these this water through a filtration
so the liquid waste which is usually
produced by the gills and the urine of
the fish
gets processed through a biofilter and
this gets normally recirculated around
even in a general
aquaculture system
but
the solid waste has to be collected as
well so that's your manure if you let
that accumulate and build up ammonia
toxicity will happen you also gunk up
your system and it's no good
but a lot of times
aquaculturalists and even aquaponic
producers will take this solid waste and
just flush it down the toilet which is a
waste
because
well it's a it's a real waste because
you're spending a lot of money on fish
food and this food becomes poop and well
there's a lot of nutrients that we can
take out of this poop
so my experiment is specifically
focusing on the three different ways of
microbially processing this waste into
usable hydroponic fertilizer
so i've gone ahead and made three
different bacterial digestion chambers
so first we have an anaerobic tank
an aerobic tank and then an anaerobic
tank so it gets processed for the full
four weeks and then moved to the aerobic
tank where it gets another process for
another four weeks um so each of these
tanks have unique set of microorganisms
that will digest their solid waste oh
yeah they're all heterotrophic so
they're taking this organic waste and
basically turning it into a usable
inorganic mineral nutrient for
hydroponic fertilizer
now this is really important
for a lot of different reasons so we can
stop a lot of nutrient leaching from
going into waterways by just you know by
dumping that
excess waste like we don't really want
to be doing that and by turning into a
usable product like we're contributing
to the circular economy
also just for aquaponic producers
a lot of times just by using the fish
water they all have nutrient
deficiencies
specifically in potassium iron calcium
sometimes phosphorus and
magnesium so by
taking the
waste and process again through one of
these and adding it back into your
system they can fix some deficiencies
within their system hopefully that's the
hope
and then
just in general they can spend less
money on fish feed because you're
getting more nutrients out of the same
amount of feed that you are using
and lastly if if hopefully this this
process the combined one can produce a
good enough
hydroponic nutrient
or just straight up organic hydroponic
producers so people who aren't even
growing fish themselves can buy fish
waste process it themselves and then use
it in their own hydroponic systems so
it'd be kind of like akin to like an
organic farmer buying chicken manure
putting it on their field and growing
their crops next season but instead
we're buying fish waste putting it in
barrels
and then growing it hydroponically
uh so
next up that's weird um i've been i've
been tracking the nutrient makeup of all
of my bacterial tanks and i have some
preliminary results outside take a look
at later
and i am testing each
each
nutrient so we have one of four in here
and another one of four in here against
each other and against a conventional
hydroponic fertilizer to see which one
does best so fingers crossed it works
out but uh yeah i'll be happy to take
any questions or discuss my research
outside of my project or my poster thank
you
[Applause]
cool
hi everybody um
so
my capstone project well first of all
i'm in public garden leadership
and my advisors are
uh don raquel and sonia skeles thank you
for being here
um so i'm looking at how
public gardens can adopt seed sharing
programs
um
and i'll tell you a little bit more
about what seed sharing programs are and
then how they intersect with public
gardens
um
so seed sharing programs uh typically
like the most common one you'll hear
about is the seed libraries i don't know
if anybody's heard of a seed library but
they've been popping up all over the
united states really rapidly in the past
couple of years
most of the time they're at um
public libraries and they're just any
institution that
basically gives away seed for free and
it's really great because it allows
people to
try out growing seeds it's really good
to get people into gardening get people
excited about certain
issues um so i think that public
libraries have really found that it's a
fantastic programming tool that they can
use and then other organizations too
like colleges and universities there's
actually a c library here at cornell
that opened up this year
other churches other community groups
are finding it really helpful to build
community
to establish a culture of sharing
and all different types of programming
opportunities
that that see libraries are really good
at establishing
but so far
public gardens have been slow to adopt
seed libraries or any other type of seed
sharing programs despite the fact that
they're a really awesome education
tool that they could be using
so in my capstone project i'm looking at
the history of seed libraries
what so far has
have we seen that works really well or
what doesn't and then seeing how we can
tailor this information so that public
gardens can use it because there's
there's a significant amount of info out
there on how these libraries or other
seed sharing programs can be established
for
public libraries but since public
gardens have been slow to adopt these
programs i'm looking at how can we make
this model adaptable for public gardens
so to do that i i've researched all
different types of sea sharing programs
and then i'm
conducting interviews
with certain seed libraries or other
seed sharing programs that have
implications for public gardens and then
i'm going to write a guide that can be
used by public gardens to
think about what it is they want to
accomplish with their seed sharing
programs
and build a program that works really
well for them and is really effective
um
and specifically i want to look at you
know the specific needs
that public gardens have and their
specific capabilities and limitations
and challenges
and
by recognizing those things help them to
approach the planning process so that
they can implement the seed sharing
program that works really well for them
there is a ton of different one of the
most
interesting things that i think i've
found so far is that there's a really
wide range of reasons that certain
institutions will implement a seed
sharing program
it started out as sort of a kickback
against the core for control of
agriculture and genetic engineering but
it's and so people wanted to preserve
different seed varieties that were going
extinct at a rapid rate but now it's
more a lot of different programs are
geared to just getting people into
gardening but there's also interest in
food justice in
native plants and conservation so it can
really be a tool for a number of
different things
and my guide will help
different public gardens assess what
they want to do with the seed sharing
programs and then design a program that
works to really connect them into their
community and be effective
and that's it
[Applause]
it sounded like you were going to do
specific things for specific gardens
based on what they want
i'm gonna be
so
the guy that i'm gonna write is just
gonna sort of
outline considerations that public
garden should take when they're in the
planning process things that they might
not have thought of of the limitations
they have staffing they have what type
of seeds they should source because
there's a lot of contention around you
know what type of seed should be
sourcing um
and then it will help them to think
through those problems
define what they want to get out of the
program because like i was mentioning
people it runs the gamut of people doing
seed libraries
to
push back against corporate agriculture
just to people simply wanting to get
people into gardening and then there's
others focused on native plants so
if a
help helping a garden to recognize
really what it wants to do and then what
are the challenges associated with
certain types of programs how can they
plan for that and how can they best fit
their program
yeah thank you
all right so that's all the talks we
have so um
i would like to
thank all of our students who presented
today so i know that there's a lot going
on and getting up in front of a group of
people and talking about a project that
might not be completed yet can be
challenging and so i want to recognize
how valuable it was to have you guys do
this i think it was fantastic to see
everything that you're doing and and i
hope i didn't lie when i said we really
do have a diverse
ambitious group of students i think this
was pretty awesome
um so let's just take a second and just
thank everybody
[Applause]
and and also while we're here and i know
we have a lot of advisors in the room
i'd like to take a moment and just thank
all of our advisors for helping us and
taking all of this time to guide us
through the process of finding these
questions and getting these solutions so
let's thank all the advisors
[Applause]
the last thing and she's busy right now
but let's all thank tara because
everything
[Applause]
didn't exist without tara and and uh all
of the presentations being lined up soon
being lined up the lunch being lined up
everything is made possible by what
she's done so let's give her another
review
[Applause]
and so now we have uh some food and so
uh and invite you to sit down with
somebody who just presented and and pick
their brain and talk to them a little
bit we can use this room for lunch we
can also it's beautiful day we can go
outside and enjoy the weather
during the lunch we also have some
posters set up so as you get done your
lunch you can mingle over there if you
have questions that you didn't get
answered or you have ideas you know stop
by the poster of the person who's
presenting and and ask them some
questions so enjoy uh so we only have
the one section of presentations we'll
have lunch and the posters and then you
guys hang out as long as you want and
then we're free to go and we're ready
okay
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu